to irreconcilable views of the same
region
western governments say gross human
rights abuses are being carried out
against the uyghur people in xinjiang
china and says xinjiang is a wonderful
land full of happy people
whose rights are protected today it
unveiled sanctions against individuals
and organizations in the uk
who disagreed with that accusing them of
interfering in its internal affairs
and spreading lies xinjiang definitely
does not deserve the negative attention
it is getting
right now the human rights in xinjiang
cannot be defined by a few satellite
images
fake reports covered together by people
thousands of miles away all the
performance
by anti-china actors or actresses
this is unfair to 25 million people
living in the region the chinese
measures were retaliation for the first
ever british sanctions on chinese
officials
announced on monday the foreign
secretary had his own response today
we will not be silenced in terms of
speaking out about these human rights
abuses
and i think you'll see as we saw earlier
this week with 30 countries including
the uk
united imposing sanctions on those
abusing the
uyghur muslims and others in xinjiang
you'll see that pressure continue to
grow
to grow and to rise four conservative
mps were targeted
including surrey and duncan smith and
tom tugandat along with two peers a
lawyer and an academic
and four groups they will all be banned
from entering china hong kong and macau
their property if they have any in china
will be frozen and chinese citizens and
institutions will be prohibited from
doing business with them
but the trouble extends to businesses as
well clothing companies nike and h
m have refused to use cotton from
xinjiang and are now facing calls for a
boycott
in the country as far as i'm concerned i
intend to continue to speak out
many of my colleagues have spoken out
we've had
attempts to silence us by the chinese
already um
and we will do again as i said earlier
on in one of my statements
you know speaking out for the for the
weaker people and others who have no
voice at the moment is a badge of honor
for us considering what they're going
through
politicians are unlikely to stop talking
but western businesses in china are
under pressure
this spontaneous boycott comes with
serious backing from the chinese
government
i think that what these retailers are
doing is not good
with the way things are now then i will
not buy anything from these brands
as long as these brands are not
insulting china then i'm okay with any
of them
but if they are insulting china then i
will definitely boycott them
these actions by our country are very
much correct i've looked into these
issues
and i feel that certainly one has to
support one's motherland
china is doubling down on xinjiang
making it clear that criticism
comes with a cost by drawing the line
though it may find more people than it
thought standing on the other side
tom cheshire sky news beijing